in the world
hello and welcome everybody
it is September 19th 2020 23. we're here
at the octave inference Institute in
guest stream 58.1
and today the session will be around the
experiences of those who have worked
with Gerald Edelman
Edelman lived from 1929 to 2014 and as
hopefully this conversation can explore
and unpack a little bit worked in
various areas related to the brain body
and mind
so without further Ado I will have our
guests introduce themselves give a
little bit of a background on how they
came to be working with Professor
Edelman and then we have several
prepared questions and several other
questions so thank you all for joining
and perhaps Andrew if you'd like to
begin
all right so uh I'll just start a little
bit with my background I did my PhD at
University of Minnesota
um and then I did my postdoc at Hopkins
with Apostles georgopoulos and Vernon
mock Castle
and then I got a job in Phoenix working
in a small uh Neuroscience Institute or
neuroscience
department at a hospital
and uh I worked there for six or seven
years and my interest was working with
uh non-human primates with monkeys and
studying how they uh reached for
different objects and Drew objects
and then looked at the activity in
primary motor cortex neural and we
carried out uh different kinds of
analysis based on the directionality of
the neurons in motor cortex built
populations and were able to actually
look at these neural signals and see how
they corresponded in a pretty exact way
to the way the animals are moved in time
and space in other words trajectories
and um
after working there six or seven years I
was invited to come and look at this new
Institute that Gerald Edelman was
establishing in San Diego in La Jolla
and met a bunch of super interesting
people like Guilio tanoni and Olaf's
Barnes and uh really their deep
intellect and curiosity and creativity
is convinced me to move to San Diego
um
and uh
so I ended up moving there and so
Edelman
uh was able to build this gorgeous
research facility on the Torrey Pines
Cliffs basically and uh
it was a magnificent architecture
and he recruited uh a number of people
besides uh spawns and tanoni and so he
divided the group into theorists and
experimentalism I was an experimentalist
but we'd have lunch every day together
as a group and uh
discuss different topics and and I was
really exposed to a whole new way of
thinking about Neuroscience in terms of
sort of the cognitive aspects of it
which I still have difficulty with to
tell you personally because I don't even
know how you Define cognition and I'm
not sure that anybody really can or as
Vernon Mark Castle would say I don't
know the answer to that nor does anybody
else
maybe Karl would uh take issue with that
um but anyway the coolest thing about it
was being really exposed to a lot of
creative thinking and deep intellectual
Endeavors and I've really never
regretted that seven or eight years I
spent there I think it really helped
change the way my career went
um from being sort of a motor control
strict
sort of uh you know very careful
scientist to using my imagination a lot
more than I would have otherwise
so I'll leave it at that
awesome
Ching Ming
um okay yeah I think that uh speak about
uh my my uh Journey with Dr Edelman so I
was originally uh from Taiwan I
graduated with a medical degree in
Taiwan University uh in 78 but I was
very interested in doing basic science
so I applied the PHD program and got
into Rockefeller University and that you
know started to search for a laboratory
and certainly Dr Edelman you know with
his very powerful intellectual capacity
building
on the in the building you know it was a
ninth floor of the Bronx laboratory I
was very impressed so I I joined the
laboratory
um so um since 78 to 83 I was a PHP
student
and I was working on the topic called um
called neural cell adhesion molecule so
at that time element already got his
Nobel Prize for immunogram but he would
be you know usually you know in use
usually elegant way but to say I solved
the molecular recognition so he said I
don't want to be stay in Immunology to
collect more Awards he said I will work
out the cell recognition so in his mind
that the cell wholesale recognition work
is through a group of artificial
molecular interaction uh so that that's
how he starts to work on the cell
adhesion molecule and the duties house
actually work out the chicken cell or
tissue molecule so when I joined the
laboratory my PhD since was work out
um the first mammalian cell adhesion
molecule and in addition to end candle I
supposed to work out on these um a
tissue molecular media in the new law
cell recognition as he said he would say
you know I asked him oh so after all
what would be my PhD thesis and he was
the same mean
you know when I start to write a poem I
don't know how it's going to end you
know that's the way he would put his
language there so he said just figure
out a retinal tactile projection you
know so that you know I'm hard-working
student so I would work out on that and
as you know these days our so-called our
systems biology approach right is this
transcriptome single cell are in the
sequencing to identify a non-biased way
to identify molecules involved at that
time the so-called systems biology
approach was making monoclonal
antibodies
so I would be there taking out the brain
you know and the retina and the tech
talk take them and produce I produce 18
batch of this of the monoclonal antibody
against these these neuronal cell
membranes so I certainly have identified
a lot of adhesion molecule but
um none of them really show a very
distinct pattern I mean these days I
think we I mean the field using the
transcription factors was able to
identify some patterns but at least
later it's kind of all altogether but
um I I remember that actually no I so
anyway that's enough I didn't really
figure out the retinal sector projection
but that's enough for me to to graduate
um but
um
um at that time though I also still
remember you know how I actually um it
has a great impact on my professional
career so I was cutting chicken spinal
cord you know cross-section to mapping
resale adhesion molecules
so I have some feather chicken feather
hanging outside there and they stand
with this end came with the most
beautiful Exquisite pattern you know I
mean brain I data work on the feather as
my major research model kind of as a
rosetta song to understand the language
of morphogenesis but today I remember
how I started is that you have this
feather they form these branches so
these branches are actually originally
formed cells when they die to become
space but before they die they actually
light up with n camp right up with ncam
with the most exclusive pattern there uh
so you kind of say okay you're going to
carve out this region you light up with
and cam you light up with the Sonic and
then other signal coming to say you die
but before they die they light up that
pattern so the feather pattern is very
Exquisite radio Symmetry by natural
symmetry bilateral asymmetry so anyway
was very impressed by those you know
those findings and
um so that you know that I appreciate he
actually encouraged that he he when he
sees something he appreciate he he goes
he he encouraged it he didn't say oh
you're supposed to work on the brand or
whatever he actually like it and
subsequently he also you know developed
this idea of couple biology which he
would acknowledge to say it's sort of
based on the very Exquisite pattern we
found in the in the feather but of
course he developed it further but some
other time he would say if this is not
in feather I'm going to I am adamant I'm
going to get another Nobel price so I I
like it let him encourage that direction
so later when I became independent I
sort of say okay you know a brand is
wonderful but it's all like being curved
inside I don't figure it out but I'm not
that smart but I might be able to figure
out the further pattern formation also I
have a reasonable successful career I'll
figure out you know the Evo-Devo of
the feather but but as I said not just
the feather itself but use feather as as
a as a result to figure out
morphogenesis and uh that uh sort of I
think I appreciate that his encourage of
that and also you know as you know the
stem cell biology comes along and the
feather in a bird you know baby chicken
is one way adult chicken male female all
looks differently but they are all from
the same group of the same cell that's
my lab have demonstrate so it is the
so-called stem cell niche would be
modulated by sex hormone by age by
season by temperature and then help you
produce different feather forms to to
let them to adapt to the environment so
so I I think I I enjoy my research
career and it was obviously I have his
impact and I think he's intellectually
brilliant and always encouraged going
after
fundamental principles saying that if
you're going to work on a question ask
the most profounded questions and
approach with the most available
technology other technology of the day
you know don't waste your time on small
questions and and I think I have to take
those in so I can say up to here and we
can discuss more later
thank you awesome! Karl?
all right sir my name is Karl friston
and like my two colleagues I found my
stay with Jerry Edelman both
foundational and very very formative
um I was quite early in my research
career when I joined the Neuroscience
Institute
um having trained as a psychiatrist I
got into brain Imaging and at the
Inception of brain Imaging people were
for the first time discovering
principles of functional brain
organizations such as the principal of
functional segregation and subsequently
principles of integration has segregated
um specialized parts of the brain
Communicator or coordinated or are
integrated together and one of the key
theoreticians and neuroanatomists that
um
authored this particular interpretation
deployment of neuroimaging with Samir
Zeki and Semir Zeki for those of you
don't know it's it's still very active
uh one of the architects of the of newer
Aesthetics
um in his late retirement now but he was
friendly with Jerry Ackerman and Semir
was um famed for
um understanding the computational
anatomy of early visual cortex and
visual cortical hierarchies and the
um and I repeat the principles of
functional specialization and
integration
um so after a couple of years
um at the inception of
the human brain mapping using positron
emission tomography and establishing
um this um for example the color Center
in the in a particular part of the
visual cortex I was effectively sent to
New York
um so my period of um engagement was a
um a fellowship between about 1990 and
1992-93 so this slightly predates Andy
um and it covered the
um translocation of The neurosciences
Institute from the Rockefeller
University to
um La Jolla um and the uh under the
auspices of the Scripps so I spent you
know half my fellowship at the
Rockefeller and then subsequently
watched the building of the magnificent
neuroscientist Institute on North Tory
Pines Road that Andy referred to with
the auditorium if I remember designed by
imported experts in audition and music
and sound engineering from Sweden it was
a really an amazing place I I do
remember a couple of lunches um before I
returned to the UK to pursue my career
in imaging neuroscience
um under the auspices of the Wellcome
trust
um but only a couple because we were
sort of in rented accommodation from the
scripts on the other side of the road
but it was an awe-inspiring bit of
architecture both intellectually and
um practically in terms of uh the you
know the early days of the Neuroscience
Institute. And so I was sent there
basically uh because some music thought
it would be good for me to go and work
with Jerry Edelman
um retrospectively I now appreciate that
I was um sent there to replace a gentle
called Read Montague
who had been tasked with on the pure
theory side as opposed to the solidation
molecule and the wetnab um side of uh
Edelman's research
um on the pure theory side
um on the point of my arrival and to a
certain extent at the point of Read's um
brief uh exposure
um to The Neurosciences Institute the
theory of neural group selection was
becoming consolidated and in particular
what drove the selection of neuronal
groups neural Ensemble cell assemblies
however you want to describe them and
given
um
Edelman's
portion for incredibly incisive in um
and
um straightforward but very creative
biological thinking he thought well it's
obviously some kind of natural selection
um and therefore there must be the
homologue of adaptive Fitness that is
underwriting the scaffolding and the
dynamic
um uh structuring of connectivity or
connections that were definitive
Definitive of in the spirit of
functional specialization of segregation
but also the mediator of functional
integration
um of these neural cell neuronal groups
so this
um this became known generically as
value
um so Read was working on
value-dependent learning the plasticity
and the principles that underwrite which
synaptic connections have the right kind
of adaptive Fitness in their milia in
that context that enabled them to
persist and other connections went away
and became
or contributed to the you know the
sparse coupling of neural networks and
then read
um
and we can talk about the other glorious
stories about the the the departure of
Read
um Reid actually ended up um in a rather
circuitous way with uh Terry Sejnowsky at
the salt and subsequently then hooked up
with people like Peter Diane and Wolfram
um Schultz uh who at that time was in
Zurich and of course this the you know
the story that emerged on that was the
reward prediction error story
um that um actually ironically uh Read
did not but a number of all from
um eventually got the brain prize for
some decade or so later but the
Inception of that story was actually at
the Rockefeller
um and it was um basically uh
a
than attempt by I think Read to
formalize the pr the principles or that
must be in play to make the theory of
neural group
um selection under what were important
what was an important
um dynamic from Edelman's point of view
which is the notion of re-entry
Dynamics so very very early on
um he had identified the the fundamental
points of of recurrent connectivity and
re-entry as very formative in um the you
know the emergence of these structured
groups and the um associated functional
specialization
um and just (open brackets) just to point
out that you know you could
um you could claim that certainly his
early conversations with with
um
but people are at that time so preempted
stuff in computational Neuroscience that
we now would take as of for granted not
really realizing where it came from but
certainly his work with Vernon Mountcastle
I'm sure Andy will be able to speak to
this later on on your the importance of
re-entry and dynamics and oscillations
in the formation of these groups and
sort of cortical columns and the like
that was a sort of I think
um you know the monographs that they not
the monographs but the the the the
papers and the articles they wrote at
that time I think were quite visionary
um Stephen grossberg was also hanging
around a few years earlier and I think
you could probably claim that between
the two of them they invented
computational Neuroscience certainly
a la you know New York, Boston sort of
uh you know the East Coast kind of um uh
um style of of computational
Neuroscience personally involved with
something called the Neuroscience
Research Foundation so that they they
as I understand it and again Andy may
want to correct me here but this was
like the um the forerunner the Society
for Neuroscience it was a group of
people people
um and perhaps Max Cowan [[1931-2002]] is as the name
that comes to mind people who actually
invented words like Neuroscience uh
which wasn't a thing certainly when I
was applying to to you know to to my
undergraduate studies
um and trying to create institutions
academic institutions that would endorse
this notion of Neuroscience and the
Neuroscience Research Foundation was
like the old guard and then The Young
Turks came along and reacted against the
um the Old Guard the Neuroscience
Research Foundation to form the society
for neuroscience and then we all know
the story uh since that time it's now
one of the biggest Societies in in
Academia
um so it's just making the point that
Edelman and um you know his colleagues
and vicarious colleagues uh you know a
lot of people Oliver Sacks being one
Ernst Mayr being another of his
favorite sort of
um characters to talk to all of whom
would come and visit and we were
privileged just to listen in and
conversations in this very formative
time where some of the sort of I think
conceptual pillars of the way that we
understand
your Neuroscience uh
um uh you know in the 21st century were
um were first
articulated probably not using quite the
same words that that we use nowadays so
no one talks about re-entry anymore it's
all about recurrent neural networks or
sort of
um uh feed forward and feedback and
they're like but the same underlying
Dynamics and maths I think is absolutely
there anyway I was brought in to replace
Read Montague
um so that was my little contribution
um whilst we're in the Rockefeller
um
I made the mistake of
um thinking that the right way to do
this was to actually write down
equations and try and sort of naturalize
it in terms of in terms of mathematics
Edelman was a great biological thinker
he was not a very good mathematical
thinker
um so there was a bit of a clash there
so I I remember one
one meeting
um very early on when it was being
decided what I was going to be doing
um and perhaps it's useful just to say
the context and you know in which those
those early meetings took place so Andy
Owen has already mentioned Giulio Tononi
and Olaf Sporns they were two key uh
people uh Edelman's young men who
already already in inside you
um and then I replaced read
um and they were working really purely
on Theory
um and that theory was tested in the
context of uh it was a a forerunner a
supercomputing a hypercube that was
driving in my day little robots so again
you know Edelman was doing neurorobotics
in the 1990 or 1980s
um in exactly the same way that people
now in developmental neural neurobotics
are are still addressing exactly the
same questions
um probably with with the same kind of
computer infrastructure that obviously
upgraded
um so
um we were sitting around and later
amongst uh called out to take a a phone
call from from Germany um and there was
a look of horror on people's faces
because I'd suggested a relationship
between value dependent learning and the
risk scholar Wagner rule
from behavioral psychology and and as
soon as I you mention an equation or a
formula that set Ada went off and I
didn't know that so I didn't know I
pushed the road man so when everyone
came back in I was effectively
rusticated I was prevented from doing
any work
um for three months and for every day
afternoon and morning I had to sit in
the Rockefeller library and read purely
biological great texts and I ended up
having to the last one was "The Growth of
Biological Thought" by Ernst Mayr I had
to read from from page to page and when
I did so I become sufficiently sanitize
be allowed back into the workplace to
actually do some work anyway
um so that that was our contribution uh
and then when we moved to
um you know the whole
um parade of 16 wheeler tracks is
transportating all the kids and all the
um all the paperwork to
um to La Jolla and then relocating out
there settling down
um I brought that work to closure and
the interesting that was that the point
when Giulio well Olaf I remember in
saying you know
what he wants is basically to understand
the and simulate
um the uh the brain
um in a way that is
um draws explanatory power from the
architecture of the connectivity it
basically would say he wants to be he
wants to establish connectomics
um as as a discipline and of course you
know 10 years later he's Mr. Connectomics!
uh Guilio at that point was
um inventing Integra integrated
information Theory
um with a particular focus on
information theoretic formulations of
complexity and what special if you like
counter-intuitive behaviors do you get
from these biologically configured
connectors when you put Dynamics on
structure and trying to quantify that in
a way that ultimately
um transpired to be measures like Phi in
IIT
um so that that was a fun time as the
math
closet mathematician because I wasn't
allowed to to say anything about the
maths at the time I enjoyed that bit and
sort of looking
um you know
um being in uh at the if you like um
Ground Zero at the inception of all
these all these aspirations I mean which
eventually led to very fruitful careers
and then I went back
um to
um uh to the UK just had fond memories
and a non-fond memories uh but both of a
nostalgic sorts at some time
awesome
great Tales changing or Andrew anything
you want to add or I can go to one of
the questions
well uh just to expound a little bit on
what Karl was saying I don't know if you
can see this book okay so this was uh
something that came out of the
Neuroscience research program that was
sort of the uh old boys club that
Francis Schmidt
um started at MIT and later was the
basis for the neurosciences Institute
and what this was sort of the who's who
in Neuroscience so again if you look at
this book it says edited by Francis o
Schmidt so he was the guy that started
that
and uh so this persisted even
to the uh throughout the 2000s
um and uh so once or twice a year uh at
The neurosciences Institute they would
organize one of these meetings and it
would be a who's who of Neuroscience so
all the Nobel laureates and Neuroscience
all the big names would come for uh four
or five day meeting and talk about their
research and as a member of The
neurosciences Institute I got to sit in
and meet these people and it was a
phenomenal especially for with my
background because I was sort of a not
on the the mainstream of neuroscience at
that point and uh that was a really
fascinating so you got to meet people
like will Schultz and
and all the the big names
um that were there Francis Crick
um you know and uh but what I want to go
back to is this original book by Edelman
and my castle called the mindful brain
this is sort of like one of the uh
Bibles of early creative thinking about
brain function and it
he says the idea that of distributed
systems this was sort of the thing that
Vernon montcastle was very much into
um and so the to this day the way most
people think about brain function is
boxes uh where each part of the brain is
confined to a box and then there are
arrows pointed to other boxes and so we
get this idea that there's a circuitry
so you often hear
neuroscientists talk about circuits and
that kind of comes from the idea that
you have these boxes and you have arrows
and you have plus and minus signs with
the arrows and then somehow the pluses
and minuses add up and tell you what's
going to happen at the next box
um and that is nice because you can kind
of simplify things and talk about
causality in in very concrete terms and
it's great if you're an engineer because
you can write transfer functions about
defining how you can output from an
input
but that's not the way the brain works
and you know I think Kyle can attest to
the early days of uh MRI
studies where everybody was doing
pseudo-colored
um
representations of these different areas
to see which area would light up in a
particular task as if each area had a
specific job and could be assigned to a
specific task
and
so Neuroscience in general still
suffering from that point of view and
it's only become a little bit more clear
as computational science has matured in
the last five or ten years especially
with uh you know adaptation of
artificial neural networks to the
mainstream
that you know we can start to explore
more biological meaningful ways of brain
function
and you know Verner mock Castle
recognized that you know as a sort of
the uh I would say the founder of
systems Neuroscience modern systems
neuroscience
and Edelman talked about that a little
bit you know this group Theory and some
of the things that oleff has started
um you know with graph Theory
still sort of based on strict anatomical
connectivity
and you know if you read like Olaf's
latest review where the field is
starting to progress away from that
constraint of anatomical connectivity
we're starting to get more toward the
idea of truly distributed systems and to
me that that's super exciting but you
can look back to this book you know from
the 70s and see that the seed was
planted way back then and see how you
know almost 50 years later now is
finally starting to evolve into
something that's becoming more
mainstream and if you sort of look at
the evolution of Neuroscience
I think if you project ahead to the next
10 or 20 years this is going to be
really the fundamental change in the way
we think about neural function and uh
I'm super excited about that and you
look and sort of back in history to see
how that's evolved and uh
I don't know I I think there's a
something very attractive about thinking
about things that way
um yeah okay yeah okay I'll add
something I think talking about the you
know elements uh Circle so so the
ingredients about you know seeing things
through I I I don't know in the neural
biology field you people still sort of
seeing the neurology is an idea it's
still there right yeah
so that was the time when I was uh with
him in Rockefeller University uh he
would talk things like that you know uh
Darwinism for evolution species and he
he saws that in immunological
selection so he applied to the to this
neurota with some idea uh but I have to
say you know subsequently I actually my
career is mainly in University Southern
California and uh working on this
morphogenesis pattern for me tissue
pattern formation and in our field in a
sort of more bench work you know aspect
of element you know this direction not
the neural biology Direction but in the
field there were people originally more
talking about the stem cells are
predetermined and then they go listen
yes
but we using the skin as a model
actually you know I start to write these
things kind of a Darwinism within the
skin I mean basically is that there is
no preset forever stem cells if you wipe
out these stem cells other cells are
waiting there to take over the space so
there is even during development and
during regeneration to make the tissue
patterning process robust there is a
small so-called Darwinism competition
going on in there and the less is sort
of also influencing my our our work in
morphogenesis these days and I think
that's kind of the impact of him on this
aspect as well yeah
wow
all right I'll read a question this was
from Dave Douglas
Dave wrote
we know that Professor Edelman use deep
analogies in exploring new subjects as
in his leveraging his knowledge of
immunology and organismal development to
probe conceptualization and learning did
he ever work specifically on metaphor
and analogy as such for example did he
leverage his experience of music and
poetry to dig out scientific facts while
separating fertile from sterile
analogies
an answer or just what that makes you
think of
it makes me think of something which
Edelman used to call me which I am an
intellectual Thug so I'm sure that there
it's the great answer to that excellent
question and it does speak to Edelman's
skills and interests as a violinist
um I do remember that BBC Horizon came
to
um do a profile on him and his ideas and
it was uh prefaced with uh I think shots
of of him playing the violin you know to
concert standard uh but I have
absolutely no idea whether he used those
that that sort of part of his life to uh
um to um take things Beyond a metaphor
so as an intellectual Thug
um I'm gonna hand over to my two
colleagues whether they can give a more
elegant answer
or or anything in that area of the Arts
and you brought up poetry
anything in the Arts and Sciences
well I
I'm no no biologist if I just say that
from my side of the interaction you know
I mean he really tried to to merge our
science and art and he would think you
know a real science would be beautiful
and I and that's the way I think when I
learned as I mentioned you know uh when
I say oh I I was expecting a more
clear-cut CC's idea but he would say you
know Ming is like writing a poetry he
said that when I start I don't know
where it's going to end uh you know it's
like some artists when you ask them uh
how do you create this painting I I try
to ask this question to some of my
friends who are artists and they say
they say they do not they do not have a
clear blueprint of how that painting
what it looks like they have an idea
it's kind of floating in the sky and
they try to grab it down so they paint
on the way and then try to to make it
into a painting or I have a friend who
appointed I ask them this they say they
go up the world to make them come in
town and I kind of feel Adam I thought
about three to the the scientific idea
idea like that you know that's the you
know this is my superficial you know
an interaction yeah
uh yeah just some experience
so I don't have a
correct reply to that but I you know in
general
um I think there's the idea of
creativity
that that he brought to the Forefront
and then also you know with that
creativity there you have to have a
certain amount of Courage
to
move out of the sort of mainstream right
so if you have an idea
and you have to have a certain amount of
courage to put that forward uh
that if that idea is creative and out of
the ordinary and I think artists and
sort of uh
really great scientists have that
in common
maybe to that Nexus of creativity and
career development and courage
for you or just in the environment how
did his mentoring
help bring out these threats in people
for better and for worse I I think Karl
will could have tested that I I have a
hard time viewing Edelman as a as a
feel-good mentor
I think he would throw ideas out there
he could be pretty aggressive and uh
I would say frightening to young people
um so I I wouldn't
I wouldn't cast Edelman's behavior as
sort of the typical mentor
um but uh again I think the environment
that he created was someplace that was a
really special and reflected that kind
of courageous creativity
um and I really appreciate that now
you know just to endorse that notion of
courageous creativity
um I think it's a really nice
observation I've often reflected on
whether
um let's take for example
um Guilio and Olaf and I think you could
probably apply it to me and Andy and a
number of other people uh as well but if
we just take take Guilio and Olaf who
both become world leaders thought
leaders in their own particular field
having brought something new to the
table
um and in some in some instances in you
know more than one area so Guilio turnone
in terms of
um sleep research and synaptic
homeostasis
um in terms of his work in Consciousness
studies integrated information Theory
um Olaf in terms of structural and
function and connectomics I mean is the
is it that Edelman had a good eye for
bright young men
or is it that bright young men learned
how to do this that this was the way to
be courageous and so it's an adversarial
in that courage to be creative and to
pursue what you have created
um in a slightly adversarial or at least
sort of defensive way I I I'm not I I
don't know but what I do know is
um there were certainly a culture that
was
um established that would allow those
kinds of
um skills to be developed and you know
and is refer to them slightly obliquely
and it was uh you know it was a dark
culture it was uh and it has to be said
it was a very homophilic culture there
were no women allowed in this culture so
the you know in my time they
um the culture was really one man and
adoring young men
um and you had to
um repeatedly affirm that adoration and
part of that was
um really useful and really enjoyable
um and has already mentioned the uh the
lunches that exactly the same regime
um you know characterized my stay there
was a you know a rigorous routine where
all the young men would go off to the
New York Cafe we'd have onion rings and
and burgers uh and a remembrance wax
lyrical and
perhaps this is not art and creativity
but it was he was
um he was artistic in his joke telling
so he'd always have a new joke every
every lunch time in a New York uh diner
and that was a routine and it was just
pure theater day after day after day
incredible energy but it was theater the
young men were the audience
um and we basically
um
I think were
um dancing to you know his orchestration.
he was the conductor and he was the
director.
if that culture if that it's possible
that that culture did actually instill
in all of us and particularly Olaf and
Guilio
um the notion that to make it to make a
difference and to be true to one's
convictions you really have to sort of
fight for and be autonomously pursue
what you want to do. and it is it's
interesting that the the style in which
both Guilio and Olaf have pursued their
their scientific ideology and ideas and
creativity is very much is it's slightly
lonesome you know the
um with the exception of Guilio's work um
in um in the microbiology of sleep
um the theoretical contributions are
very sort of you know associated with
them personally and to a certain extent
with me. and um you know what one could
argue is
um then you know the um the mathematical
version of value-dependent learning
which would um be the free energy
principle all of these things have the
same flavor as neural Darwinism (or as some
people used to call it neural neural
Edelmanism).
um and so I I often asked that question
was it what was this the skill of
Edelman in choosing people who are going
to make a difference or did he basically
provide a culture in which it gave
people the the tools or the
um the motivation or the confidence that
you can make a difference because you
saw you saw him make a difference I
don't know.
um yeah I think most of you actually you
know said something I I share the
experience definitely he set up a right
environment. uh but just like when we do
stem cell stem cell and it's niche you
need the interaction you need a
conversation between epithelia and the
messenger cells or in the brain I heard
that it's more like interaction between
pneumonal cells and we are sales so a
successful interaction with the leader
whatever the process to move forward and
but not every process would be would be
would be successful so as as I said I
also you know like the way Kyle
mentioned about the animals is
is the conductor he actually said that
in our lab meeting at the time he said I
and Adam and I am the conductor you know
I you know you guys you know it's my my
symphony players and uh and you you you
pray together you can make a good music
and
um but it's also true uh not every
interaction works because I was with him
for almost eight years or so uh not
every person worked let's put that away
that is the fact that uh so some work
some don't right? so I think people are
given that opportunity and uh as Andrew
said it's a good outstanding environment.
so so you pick up the the idea from
adamant you develop yourself and some of
them you know or what you can tell call
it the element level
and the medicine then we we success in a
certain way or not.
um but I think it's it's an exciting
environment. uh I would put it put it way
is is most you know he inspires you he
gives you a sort of an exciting
environment to evolve but not everyone
is so he can choose everyone to be
successful. no it's not like that but he
did give you that opportunity to to to
be successful and to to pick up
something. and he also give you that
courage to do it as I mentioned. you know
people would normally think you know
using the feather as a model is kind of
very very high risk but but he's he has
that encouragement and I I do that and I
I feel I really using feather as a
rosetta song I have learned something
for the morphogenesis uh pattern
formation field yeah. so I appreciate him
on that yeah.
Andrew or I can ask another question
uh I really don't have anything to add
right now.
thank you though.
it's really amazing it's
it's such a different world and the
environment of learning and of carrying
out science is so
different. so
personally I really appreciate just even
a window into
settings that are
elsewhere and in a different time. so
thank you for
all of this. all right I'll ask another
question from Dave
Professor Edelman was reputed to be
skeptical about the risk of abusing
mathematical or computer models in
creating theories of neural functioning
cognition and consciousness. some
reviewers went so far as to mock him in
print for using computers as research
tools
but he worked with Tononi
on the foundations of integrated
information Theory an extremely math
heavy theory that sometimes explained
using Computing imagery. did Edelman
change his attitude towards the role of
math or of computing paradigms and
thinking about the mind?
or did he simply start trusting his
colleagues to think computationally
without falling into rabbit holes dug by
Von Neumann and Turing?
or how did you see the role of math and
computers in Edelman's thinking and
research develop over a period where
they were also undergoing such rapid
developments more broadly?
so I I'm pretty sure that Edelman
respected mathematics and computational
approaches to neuroscience uh he
certainly there certainly were a lot of
theory fellows that were computationally
savvy uh while I was at the Institute.
um and uh so for instance uh
Karl mentioned these uh robots that were
used to sort of explore and learn sort
of the beginning I guess of embodied
cognition Karl you would say
um where they explore the environment
and learn and then from that learning
they they build internal models. so that
is a I would say and that was Olaf's
bailiwick.
I would say that that was highly
computational
um and certainly a major thrust in
Edelman's
but emphasis and what he wanted to do at
The Institute and there were a number of
other things I think the integrated
um
part that uh
Guilio did I think that was almost all
Guilio's
work along with some of the other
computational fellows. uh so uh
you know I think Edelman wanted to be
part of that but that really
I think was mostly Guilio's and uh
I I think you know as part of the
culture. uh Edelman managed to get his
name on Guilio's paper we used to laugh
about that quite a bit
um but you know again I I would say that
was 99% Guilio's work.
yeah I I can conquer because I was there
when the work was actually done there
was a um there was a sort of um period I
can't remember there was some hypothesis
that pertained to a core a Dynamical
Core as
um
um sort of
oppressions are necessary for some kind
of Consciousness. and I think Edelman was
comfortable with this sort of intuitive
notion of a dynamic core but when you
when it became articulated in terms of
information theory he
um started I he would I think
um even if he didn't say so out loud he
would have responded as he responded to
me with oh you've got mathematosis! so
hey this is this is another of his sort
of
um ways of dealing with people who had a
tendency to over mathematicalize and
oversimplify as a physicist would. you
know they're reducing a horse to a point
and then writing down differential
equations he was very allergic to that
you know he didn't like that and would
call that
um an instance of mathematosis I think
that's very distinct though from what
Andy was just talking about which is the
commitment to physically realized
embodied computation
um and you know I think it's a really
well absurd point that you know that
this was embodied cognition
um Circa 1980, 1990. so he was quite
Visionary in um I think sort of put
testing out ideas in in physical and
realized systems you couldn't just hand
away with maths. you had to show it
worked. this idea worked in a real um in
a real setting and at that time they
were
um and you know
um you know the Darwin series and you
know to the extent that um you know I
for example had to spend six months
learning to paralyze [parallelize?] C
um in order to program the robot so you
know it wasn't he was frightened of new
technology or computer science I think
he didn't like trivializing things
um your ala physicist with with
mathematics but you would certainly
um
um be fully committed to the notion that
you that the computation is at the heart
of the kind of dynamics that he wanted
to understand that and and underwrote
theory. and indeed I think that you know
the theory of neural group selection
um speaks that he wanted to see it
realized uh you know realized in in a
robot. so
um but yeah I think Andy is absolutely
right at the point when uh Guilio sort of
just basically
um we went straight from the axioms to
Consciousness and Phi with equations I I
think that was the time that Guilio had
to
um
had to leave the family basically
um and and duly[?] did so.
um
brother extrapolated that a little bit
more I think you know when I read
Edelman's books and and some of his
papers
I don't understand his words okay and
you know his phrases and his
descriptions you know a lot of things
don't make sense if he had written those
out or someone had written those out as
equations okay what you know that's the
nice thing about equations once you see
the equation you know you don't have to
worry about the word so much uh you know
things become pretty clear and I think
you know looking back if he'd been able
to do that I think his ideas
first of all would have been
crystallized in his own mind better and
second of all would have been able to be
others would have understood them more
clearly. and I think that's
really important. if you have for me okay
maybe with an engineering background or
something you know if you have a model
or if you have an idea if you can write
that out explicitly with an equation it
really clarifies things it crystallize
this thing. and that was the thing that I
liked about Guilio's work because again
this word of "Consciousness" you know it's
like nobody knows what that really means
but at least Guilio had
a form of equations right where he was
talking about information Theory and in
a way you know you could have a a
cluster where information was internal
versus the external information and say
that okay if you have to have
Consciousness here it is! and he could
describe that with a concrete equation. I
mean that's a step forward. and again I
always say as a someone that that
records neurons in the brain all the
time
if I wanted to find Consciousness how
would I know it if I found it right? I
mean if I had an equation maybe I could
do it but you know just the way it's
defined right now I mean who knows I
could have already discovered it I
wouldn't know! so uh I I think that's a
an interesting point anyway.
Karl: I can't resist just follow up on that
because um especially evident for me in
"The Remembered Present" this this notion
that his words don't actually make any
sense I think that's pure pure poetry
and pure Brilliance because what I tend
to find myself doing is writing reading
the meaning into his ambiguous sentences
and finding all sorts of
um meanings which wouldn't have occurred
to me otherwise I think that's part of
his art. I suspect that he would have
been terrified if somebody had actually
come along and tried to time down to a
clear formal naturalized mathematical
formalism because he wouldn't have had
that sort of
biotic expressiveness and ambiguity that
of course is at the heart of uh of his
evolutionary thinking. and I think it's
it you know it's it's great that you
Andy are able to say you don't
understand what he wrote. Because I I
look at some of his sentences and what
the Earth is he trying to say here and
of course but the exercise
of trying to make sense of Edelmann
itself brings to the table uh some
really interesting
um sort of associations and ideas. I I'm
wondering whether that was part of the
secret of his success
is that he resisted the temptation to be
crystal clear and just left that
mystical magical ambiguity hanging in
the air for people like you and me to to
worry about and try to resolve.
Andy:  I I suppose he's given their privilege after
winning a Nobel Prize I I think uh some
of us mere mortals wouldn't be afforded
that uh luxury
all right I'll read a few more questions
we have a few more things so small
questions
um in the book "Topobiology," Changming,
did you draw the feathers or is that
your work
feather is my work yeah it's based on my
work yeah.
awesome
um
well
how do we
take things forward in science and in
our work here in this level of
diffractal with this amazing story and
history with Edelman but how do we
take our historical and our mentoring
context? like how do you carry that
forward is it something you think about?
Karl: I personally do, and I congratulate
myself every day on not being like
Edelman when it comes to mentoring.
how so?
I'm not going to answer the "how so?"
question but you can read between the
lines! whether that's the right thing to
do or not I don't know I don't think I
don't think you could be Edelman now
um you know in 21st century uh with you
know um you know we'll be too close to
all the culture wars I think to even
entertain that style anymore and I
suspect that's quite a good thing
although you know pressure makes
diamonds.
um and as Andy says it was an exciting
one both my colleagues have said it's an
exciting informative time it was a
pressure time it was a dark time for me
um you know in terms of the system the
the dynamics of the systemic the the
personal interactions.
um but because it was pressured it made
diamonds. and and so we may be throwing
away the opportunity to make academic
diamonds and be truly creative in terms
of making things that endure like
diamonds by not having that style of
mentorship. but I'd don't think it would
be even legal nowadays to be quite
honest to run a lab like Edelman ran!
Andy: So again I mean I I think
that over the years Neuroscience yeah I
don't know about the rest of science but
it's almost become sort of
industrialized. so there's a method you
know you as a young person
um you when you finally get your own job
you have to set out and if you're at a
university environment there's certain
boxes you have to check off. you have to
get a grant you know you have to get
certain number of papers you have to get
something in "science" or "nature" in order
to get promoted you know there's there's
these steps. and I think young people are
so focused on moving through those steps
at the point in their career where
they're going to be the most creative
and their minds are the most flexible
and they can be the most productive and
you know I see that as as a shame
actually that that they're not given
this opportunity to be a little Freer in
the way they accomplish things and then
you know when they do accomplish a
modicum of success
they rely on their past Behavior so
instead of saying okay I had to go
through that in order to get tenure now
that I have tenure I'm free and I can do
something that I really want to do that
really doesn't happen because people get
stuck in a rut and uh
I see that as really holding back uh
progress in neuroscience and that was
kind of the cool thing about the
Neuroscience Institute for better or
worse we weren't allowed to go out and
get our own grants we had to rely on
internal funds but as a result the only
person we had to convince was Edelman in
order to get funded and uh to a certain
extent that allowed us to do things that
were really creative
in hindsight I think that was a mistake
because financially that was a doom for
The Institute there could have been a
hybrid approach that would have been
more productive and but then again uh as
Karl was saying the uh
the investigators would have had to have
more freedom to do that and that was not
exactly in the culture although I think
I was an outlier because I maintained a
separate lab
so I I was somewhat inoculated from that
and that made it a lot more pleasant for
me
um but uh again I see that that you know
in current neuroscience
it would be nice if people were willing
to take more chances
um and be a little more creative instead
of hoeing to the status quo
that would be uh I think uh what we need
in order to move forward
yeah
um
that um
no I I think that in terms of the
mentorship hunted you know car was
talking about I mean certainly I I have
seen people you know do very well but
but I also have the opportunity you know
sort of when I moved to Southern
California University Southern
California to uh have some interaction
with the Dr Seymour Benson and uh some
of you might probably know him I mean
you would see actually he is also very
successful but but he he when he came
out he would always have his students
around surrounding him you know very
very kindly uh I think that you know
Adam and um is brilliant but it's kind
of of the sun uh it's too bright
sometimes
people have to be distilled into the as
you say academic time and let's uh
that's that's interesting so we also
have seen some people you know didn't
get along with him uh well but still I
think they are and many many impact here
he certainly have encouraged many people
go different directions
and in terms of the academic um the the
academic future right I mean I think you
two are more talking about the
neurobiology side but on the on the
morphogenesis side now I would also say
he always emphasized the patterns you
know thinking that you know pattern is
kind of the way uh nature you know
either biological biology they leave
some some crew for us to figure out and
when I was there I remember every time
he talked about the the visual columns
uh thousand whistle they have workout he
got very excited and in fact I have a
one of my peers at that time was working
on on the visual Columns of the cat but
I think that paper let's work never
really go out to be published but anyway
more practical things I work on the
tissue tissue patterns and I I feel that
you know go you know you mentioned about
the top of biology and I again I think
that he coined the term and I think that
the term I mean I think it means a lot
because I kind of you know eventually my
career was trying to figure out uh these
signaling molecules uh because at that
time people only talk about the
signaling molecule very very important
but but the idea I'll talk about biology
is that you even position this simply by
positioning this signaling
centers in a different topology you can
actually have a lot of consequence
um so so from there and the signaling
Center can also have a different
lifetime the strength and the duration
and the the the range they can inference
so by money my by modulating you know he
likes these terms so modulating uh this
signaling Center you can create a lot of
regional differences and up to now as I
say from my own take you know but you
look at it fried feather here Downy
feather here you know the beautiful
crown feather here tail feather but
these are all from the same genome so it
actually is through the positioning of
these different signaling Center in in a
different way and you you basically have
the same same ingredient but you can
play with them by topologically temporal
space temporal and especially arrange
them and to to create a quite complex uh
pattern so so I I feel that in the
tissue patterning morphogenesis side you
know I I feel that you know his vision
is is great and I I think we still try
to work out more about how these
patterns are positioned but I think
that's sort of the direction in a more
visualized autobiology aspective we can
appreciate
awesome well perhaps if each of you
would like to give any
closing thoughts
yes I I understand to Echo
you know there's less sentiments um
I think everything that Edelman said or
try to say
um depending whether you could
understand him I think he's absolutely
right and we're slowly discovering the
truths we've just heard about typology
and the importance of patterns and of
course if you speak to somebody like
Mike Levin he'd be talking about exactly
the same thing he'd use words like basal
cognition and you know pattern formation
but he I think that we're talking about
the same uh the same principles of
biological self-organization.
um you know and Edelman I I didn't know
about topobiology.
um but I do know you know there are
other fundamental ideas that he just you
know incidental to him I am absolutely
sure I think this is a degeneracy in the
neurosciences and psychology
um you know the notion of many to one
structure function mappings for example
these are fundamental ideas which now
are take enormous for granted
um in in my world but you know you sort
of forget how much he actually
contributed
um or at least laid the seeds for and
sometimes very explicitly so it should
be acknowledged although he was as Mark
Reichel uh put it in his typically
gentlemanly fashion Edelman was a very
complicated man. He was also very
brilliant and his responsible I think
for a lot of the direction of travel and
the intellectual growth certainly of my
intellectual growth but I would say also
many aspects of of our academic
communities.
thank you Karl! perhaps Andrew?
yeah so I I would say you know uh
if there's anyone listening out there
there's something to be said about maybe
looking back
and in ancient literature that goes back
quite a bit and maybe
seeing how some of these things came
about and trying to put it together
and see that you know there's this
iteration that constantly takes place.
people ReDiscover the same thing that's
been discovered multiple times.
um and you know try to see how there is
uh a status quo in the way science works.
and then there's these outliers where
there's sort of creative bubbles that
that come to fore. and I think uh it's
interesting to think of Edelman and the
things he did and the people that were
associated with him in terms of sort of
these disruptive right they call it
"disruptions"
um and uh
how those
disruptions may have consequence many
years later.
it's it's kind of interesting you take
the Long View
so I I think it's um
maybe worthwhile thinking about this
once in a while. and uh for young people
out there
to be encouraged to think off to think
out of the normal way of doing things
once in a while. try to foster your
creativity and have the courage to to go
after some of those ideas.
I think that's a take-home message for
me anyway.
[unintelligible]
the important question let's have a
general meaning so I I think that kind
of idea she said that look at the big
picture I remember when I was there you
talk like that big pictures. so that is
where when he thinking about the
Darwinism he would say it's not only for
the species Evolution for the for the
immunological selection he would push it
to to the Grand Theory and and for me I
work on the morphogenesis I actually
would come to realize that is also what
happened at the tissue level. these cells
are competing with each other to form
that patterns and then pattern is
selected when there is a functional
advantage it will be stabilized. so so I
think the idea of saying if we're going
to do science we do we ask big questions
ask for the generalization. I I
appreciate that and certainly he is like
how you want to call it right a huge
elephant so we all touch him uh through
different side and have a different take
on that.
and and in terms of the young scientists
I also remember he likes the Chinese
proverb I I cited to him "unless he's to
say if you wanted to get a Tiger's son
you must get into Tiger's cave!" so so so
we treat it
thank you all that's a great no really
appreciate this conversation and again
thanks until next time
thank you